we know that if we have two lines that
are parallel so let me draw those two
parallel lines l and m
so that's line l and line m we know that
if they are parallel
then
if we were to draw a transversal that
intersects both of them that the
corresponding angles are equal
so this is x and this is y so we know
that if
if l is parallel to m
then
then x is equal to y what i want to do
in this video is prove it the other way
around i want to prove
i want to prove so this is what we know
we know this
what i want to do is prove if
x is equal to y
then
l is parallel to m so that we go can go
either way if they're parallel then the
corresponding angles are equal and i
want to show if the corresponding angles
are equal then the lines are definitely
parallel and what i'm going to do is
prove it by contradiction
so let's put this aside right here this
is our goal i'm going to assume i'm
going to assume that this isn't true i'm
going to assume that it's not true so
i'm going to assume
i'm going to assume
that x is equal to y
and
and l is not parallel not parallel
to m
so let's think about what type of a
reality that would create so if l and m
are not parallel and they're different
lines then they're going to intersect at
some point
so let me draw l like this this is line
l let me draw m like this they're going
to intersect by definition if something
if two lines are not parallel they're
going to intersect each other and that
is going to be m and then this thing
that was a transversal i'll just draw it
over here
so i'll just draw it over here and then
this is x
this is y and we're assuming that y is
equal to x so we could also call the
measure of this angle we could also call
the measure of that angle x
so given all of this reality and we're
assuming in either case that this is
some distance that this line is not of
zero length and so this line right over
here is not going to be of zero length
or this line segment between points
between points
a
and b i guess we could say that a b
the length of that line segment is
greater than zero i think that's a fair
assumption in either case a b is going
to be greater than zero so when we
assume that these two things are not
parallel we form ourselves a nice little
triangle here where a b is one of the
sides and the other two sides are i
guess we could label this point of
intersection c the other two sides are
line segment bc and line segment ac and
we know a lot about finding the angles
of triangles so let's just see what
happens when we go when we just apply
what we already know well first of all
if this angle up here is x we know that
it is supplementary to we know that it
is supplementary to this angle right
over here so this angle over here is
going to have measure 180
minus x
and then we know that this angle this
angle and this last angle let's call it
let's call it angle z
we know that the sum of those interior
angles of a triangle are going to be
equal to 180 degrees so we know
that x
plus 180 minus x
plus 180 minus x plus z
plus z
is going to be equal to 180 degrees now
these x's cancel out we can subtract 180
degrees from both sides and we are left
with z is equal to
zero
so if we assume that x is equal to y and
but the l is not parallel to m we get
this weird situation where we form this
triangle and the angle at the
intersection of those of those two
lines that are definitely not parallel
all of a sudden becomes zero degrees
zero degrees but that's completely
nonsensical if this was zero degrees
that means that this triangle wouldn't
open up at all which means that the
length of a b would have to be zero it
would have to be essentially you could
call it maybe like a degenerate triangle
it wouldn't even be a triangle it would
be a line these two lines would have to
be the same line they wouldn't even form
a triangle and so this leads us to a
contradiction the contradiction is that
this this line segment a b would have to
be equal to zero it would it kind of
wouldn't be there or another
contradiction that you could come up
with would be that would be that this
this
would be that these two lines would have
to be the same line because there's no
kind of opening between them so either
way this leads to a contradiction this
leads to a contradiction and since it
leads to that contradiction since if you
assume x equals y and l is not equal to
m you lead you you you get to something
that makes absolutely no sense you
contradict your initial assumptions then
it essentially proves that if x is equal
to y then l is parallel to m because
we've shown that if x is equal to y
there's no way for l not for l and m to
be two different lines and for them not
to be parallel and so we have proven our
statement so now we go in both ways if
lines are parallel corresponding angles
are equal if corresponding angles are
equal then the lines are parallel